the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right that's important concepts of
the week principal axes another one
another one symmetry all right this is
in context of things like the mass
moment of inertia matrix yes you're a
little axis there okay we haven't done
much with it yet but we're going to come
back to with all right all right pretty
good list we only had one lecture
dynamic and static balancing let's talk
about that for a second if let's talk
about static balancing tell me what's
our features of static balancing how can
you you have a quiz problem it's on the
final have an object and an axis about
which it's spinning in your act asked is
this statically balanced or not how what
would you look for Christina
G needs to be so that another way of
saying that is the axis must the axis of
rotation must pass through G is that
what you're trying to say the center of
mass okay
everybody agree about that all right now
if I have weird shaped object I know
where the center of mass is and I stick
the axis of rotation at any angle at all
through it
is it statically balanced regardless of
the where I have that axis of rotation
passing through the center of mass yes I
hear yes how about there other people
okay so how do you I think that's
probably right but how do you test it
how do you test to see that what's a
simple test you can form to see if
something is statically balanced right
so you make the axis that you're
rotating about horizontal and see if the
thing seeks a low point because if it
does it's telling you that what about
the center of mass you start going
through the axes to go to a low point
means the center of mass is somewhere
below that axis of spin right so but any
axis at all long is just through G you
are statically balanced okay
dynamic balancing what are the what
would you look for at an object you said
is this dynamically balanced or not what
kind of properties
there would be the one balanced or sided
to rotating okay so you're looking for
no unbalanced torques doesn't like you
if the objects is rotating about the
axis they packed on you won't need to
spy on us
Wow okay it's free convincing and how
okay well you put in that last caveat
then it's bad then it's getting pretty
correct
can there be a torque on it that's not
balanced and have it be dynamically
balanced which one
you can have a torque that's in the axis
of spin and around the axis of rotation
and that torque will cause what to
happen cause the rotation rate to change
right that puts energy into the system
it accelerates it and it's a torque
that's in the direction of spin that
doesn't cause dynamic imbalances but a
torque that is other than in the
direction of spin that's what that's
what a dynamic imbalance is so what are
some other ways you can say this in
terms of things like evidence of let's
say I give you H and I give you Omega
how can you just tell by looking at
those two things I give the angular
momentum and I give you this bin how can
you tell instantly whether or not it is
dynamically balanced
so if you're saying if H and Omega are
in the line they just have to be
parallel they're aligned you do not have
any dynamic imbalance okay that sound
right yeah ed you can just opposite
senses uh I think that'd be really hard
to do I don't know of any I don't think
you could I don't think you can make a
system that has an angular momentum that
is negative it's actually opposite the
direction of the rotation rate I don't
think I don't think our universe
supports that physics but anyway I think
in any case they're lined you're okay
all right let's move on so today we're
going to actually just have you work a
couple problems and you really are going
to work in groups and when you finish
one of the groups is going to come up
and fill in the blanks on the of the
answer to the problem and we'll talk
about it we're going to work two
problems and they have to do with things
that spin and as a quick review just of
information
yes
so the problem is a simple ones
basically this and I decided to
lubricate it and I and it made the wood
swell and send out won't spin at all
actually unless I let the axis spin so
it's just this problem the axis passes
through the center of mass and it looks
just like this and I've got an x axis
aligned with the axis of the rod the Z
is this way and the spin is cap Omega
and the inertia the mass moment of
inertia matrix for this problem about G
and our axis is passing through G so
maximum of inertia to matrix times Omega
gives you H so here's the mass moment of
inertia matrix
I claim is going to be diagonal and the
test of that can you tell me whether or
not I've chosen axes that disk from
symmetry you know R will be principal
axes
okay yeah so one axis that's an axis of
symmetry is down down the shaft so
that's guaranteed to be one if I chosen
one like that and any other orthogonal
pair after that doesn't matter which way
or orient them will also be so I've got
one up and went into the board so those
are principal axes for this object so
it's going to be diagonal and in fact it
looks it's M R squared over 2m l squared
over 12 and ml squared over 12 when you
work it out and if you look up in the
book most books for slant what they call
slender rods will say that this first
term is zero and that's because say an L
is a lot bigger than R the radius of
this thing and so om R squared is a
pretty small number so it's its energy
and rotation spinning this way is not
very big or its angular momentum but its
angular momentum spinning like this is
much much larger because you have much
greater mrs M R Squared's okay so you
can leave for the purpose of this
problem you can treat this as zero and
in your groups I want you to come up
with the Omega vector H and dhdt so get
do getting groups talk about it you've
got a few minutes to do this this one's
pretty straightforward then you can do
another one that's harder so you warm up
and you find a group to work in and
you're going to work a couple of
problems got a group feels pretty good
about their answer all right write it up
come up fill in the Omega H and dhdt
okay can everybody see it so you have a
Z component only for the Omega Z
component k hat only for H and it's I
Omega as easy Omega and dhdt the only
variable here is omega and you get an
Omega dot and there's no decay DT is
zero because it doesn't change direction
any questions about this yes
so the convention and if I understand
your question correctly the convention
when you write out the H vector is it's
the result of multiplying the three
components of the spin this is the piece
in the I Direction J Direction K
direction when you multiply these out
you get three results vector x so and
this one is HX and it is in the I second
one from this x it arose with middle row
gives you hy and it's into J and the
third one this vector times these three
in the bottom row give you H Z in the K
so we have capital a capital B capital C
terms in the first row and you have a
capital little a little B little C terms
and that's one when you multiply this
times this you get a a + BB + C see how
if you're multiplying like this do you
get only I had on the top
yeah well it's because this isn't just a
matrix this is actually a tensor and we
didn't we haven't gone into kind of
messy tensor notation but so you're just
being told a convention here and that is
because this is a vector being
multiplied by a tensor the result well
even though this is i j k omega x i
times this first term in this tensor
gives you an up it gives you an eye back
omega YJ x this one gives you an i back
omega z k times that gives you an eye
back right yeah that's a great question
because it was wasn't obvious we didn't
do the full tensor mathematically just
gave you a result by definition this row
times that is in the I Direction J
Direction K direction great question
okay okay so let's go on to harder
problem so you're great at that one
where we're going to do this one now so
this so we just did this problem alright
now we want to do this problem
and so the same I matrix is used here
it's this one and you can let that term
be 0 because the coordinate system that
has been defined on this object is X Z Y
into the board but the direction of spin
now is like that and we'll call it cap
Omega again but it's in that direction
and these are 45 degree angles for the
purposes of this problem so that's sine
cosine of 45 root 2 over 2 so now what's
Omega what's H and what's dhdt so
working your groups and sort that one
out you ready to go okay go for it
we'll probably do this occasionally and
I say it again I have no intention of
embarrassing you at the board so the
practice will be you put your answer up
and sit down and then we talk about it
it's not about you it's about what's on
the board okay
no put the whole thing up yep and he's
going to use that big piece of chalk it
shows better just do your right
okay so let's talk about Omega first how
do you figure - root 2 over 2 here can't
see that - root 2 over 2 Omega I 0 root
2 over 2 Omega a K or people feel good
about that any differences alright so
this thing this Omega that spin clearly
has components that are like that and
like this so this is your Z piece and
your eye piece and it is indeed in the -
I hat direction so that seems okay and H
would be some I that the I times Omega
and the first term if you take that
upper left term as 0 then you don't get
anything the second term you don't get
anything hat so how do you how do you
feel about the angular momentum any
differences okay
and the dhdt take the time derivative of
this thing I got to make a dot okay that
looks ok as far as it goes but any other
thoughts
okay dal-su okay so you're saying k hat
is changing with time and let's think
about that so it's that's this piece
here this is omega z k hat and as this
thing goes around that unit vector is
doing this right so you need a DK a DT
so do you want to give it somebody else
give me the second term here and I'll
make you sweater is yeah right
all times right too
okay this is remote mommy it's weird
okay
and then what about the root 2 over 2 oh
yo you ever kept squirt of that to write
this crazy small that gives you a half
okay and 12 and positive I started out
with a negative but cake I cross K is
minus J times the minus gives you the
plus right so this looks like this comes
out ml squared Omega squared J hat over
24 I think like that that term now okay
and people good with that now so just to
remind you when I was doing these
problems but I first had to teach this
course of free years ago and I was
trying to figure out you know easy way
to teach this and how to do these
problems I got myself all confused
trying to figure out okay which
components of the rotation vector are
rotating and what do I have to cross
into it to get the answer and in fact
you don't have to make it anywhere near
that hard and let's take a quick look at
something here H is ml squared over 12
root 2 over 2 order H cube root 2 over 2
Omega K hat
H is a rotating vector the derivative of
a rotating vector in an inertial frame
is the derivative of that rotating
vector in the rotating frame which is
the same thing as saying that Omega is
zero that's the change in length of the
vector plus Omega cross H let's test
that in to see if that gives us the
right answer this derivative gives you
all that does is gives you the theta you
mega dot back right that's that first
term the second term should just then
look like your Omega which is Omega root
2 minus root 2 over 2 cap Omega I plus
root 2 over 2 cap Omega K cross a bunch
of constants times K right so the K
cross K terms
our zero the I cross K minus J and so
you get root 2 over 2 times root 2 over
2 you get the interest get to what's in
H here multiplied by root 2 over 2 Omega
hat and you get back exactly these two
terms so it's that easy you know it's
just the derivative of a rotating vector
I'm just doing a mega cross H is the
easiest way to deal with it's derivative
of the rotating piece any rotating
vector you take this time derivative
that way alright we've got a few minutes
I want actually any other questions
about this kind of problem if you in
physics most of the problems you've
worked before were involved rotation are
planar we call planar motion problems
the axis of spin was always
perpendicular to the plane and the rest
of the problem was confined to the plane
so hockey pucks sliding along and stuff
like that and the but it was always
assumed that the axis of rotation was
perpendicular to the plane and that the
angular momentum was parallel so this is
actually this these are 3d problem this
is a 3d dynamics problem as soon as that
H and the Omega are different directions
you can come up with torques in all
three directions right ok all right is
so any other questions about this and if
not I want to talk about something that
was on the quiz ok
so here's this disc this is the one
problem on the quiz it gave more
conceptual difficulty than any other
single problem you know people made
mistakes on other problems but got into
conceptual trouble with this problem
remember you had a vehicle driving up a
bridge and the bridge could be changing
has some angular rate and it has some
angular acceleration and we said to keep
the problem simple that you could treat
this as a particle that really means you
didn't have to deal with angular
momentum I Omega for the object it's
treated like a particle and one of the
where people got when the confusion came
from was in figuring out Freebody
diagrams you're told in the problem the
language is something like the action of
the tires on the road result in a net
force up the incline called T we didn't
call it friction we didn't say anything
but people a number of people got
confused about what's that have to do
with friction
how does friction come into this okay so
let's do the Freebody diagram for this
thing so tell me what here's my car tell
me what to put on the Freebody diagram
wait okay mg alright so you got an mg
next a normal force okay that's going
this way we'll call it got T okay now
what about the tires on the road
what about friction pardon that is T so
you think of the Freebody diagram you
just say what are all the possible
sources of external force on this thing
and they come from gravity a body force
and then other things that are in
contact with it and the wheels are in
contact with the road and through the
wheels you get the normal force and
through the wheels you get any act of
friction so that is the testicle total
net friction force so and then once you
got that far you're asked to come up
with equation of motion in this
direction in the direction of the bridge
and how do you so when you go to get an
equation of motion you say that sum of
the external forces is equal to
and we'll make these in the x-direction
here is mass times acceleration in the
x-direction and how would what terms
appear pardon well those are the forces
there on the other side I want you to
come up with the accelerations you need
to come up with the acceleration terms
pardon
so this problem we'll suppose easily
think through I think in terms of r and
theta in polar coordinates because
you've been you've worked at dozens of
times with the complete acceleration of
something in a rotating system and this
is a rotating system polar coordinates
is a pretty easy good way to do this
problem so what are the accelerations in
this direction well I do it in terms of
Y in terms of r and theta yeah given a
theta dot and if they two double dot and
X an arm out up to the same thing but
I'd call it R you'll recognize the terms
in your acceleration equation so what
are the accelerations in the direction
of the bridge okay
and those are all in the collet in the I
direction and then if you look at that
that you obviously could replace our
double dot with X double dot our with X
you make your origin here you probably
would that's a point of rotation so that
is your that's the mass times
acceleration in the direction travel and
it's got to be equal to T and minus mg
sine-theta probably right and that's one
equation of motion and you're going to
do it another equation of motion in the
theta dot theta hat direction because
what other what accelerations are
present in this direction and the Y J
hat
beta double dot your oil Aryan what yeah
what else
so some of the forces in the Y so they
are in terms of polar coordinate terms
so what you said this one first plus 2
beta dot is here alright two theta dot r
dot and that's in the Tjader
and now you've got I can work the
problem so how would you go about doing
this problem where you can't treat it as
a particle any longer then we've
graduated to that because we've been
doing and we've been doing angular
momentum stuff with mass moment of
inertia matrices so now you you want to
do this more as a full-fledged dynamics
problem taking into consideration that
so how do you what is the mass what do
you have to modify the do to modify our
free body diagram there's my simplified
vehicle what are the forces on it that
you need to deal with
yeah so you can add need to because you
got two wheels on this thing and so
there's axle one here so you're going to
one here and then one here I call this
one n one and two what else
we got aji somewhere and so you still
have an mg term what other external
forces T the Nazis the problem so I was
I gave you before it's the T is the
total net force but that's not adequate
and this problem any longer
yeah so we're going to have end up
having a friction force that supplied
you know here F one and another one
applied here F 2 and F 1 plus F 2 would
be T okay so how many unknowns do we
have well it looks like four here plus
any motion stuff that you have to solve
for so how many equations of motion can
you write remember you get one equation
for every vector component direction so
XYZ gives you three components and you
could conceivably be right three
equations tell me the relevant equations
of motion that we could come up with for
this problem
okay argue about sum of forces in X
that's still true yep sum of forces in Y
you said is this zero no because that
bridge is moving okay what else okay how
do you do that some of the torques in
what direction well no yeah well you
could excuse me I shouldn't say that the
do you have more than one torque term
you can work with here more than one
torque equation
how's that
so let's just think through these things
so you can have a torque you can have a
torque and this is X Y Z out of the
board you could have as eat or making
this thing trying to pitch up and down
you could have an x-torq making it
trying to roll over but we don't have
any information in that direction and
it's constrained and we can have a Y
torque making it try to go like that and
we don't have any much information there
so it seems like we've gotten a Z torque
equation that we could write and that's
one it seems like we got three equations
Samba forces XOM forces Y and a torque
and the Z and that's it seemed like
quite enough and that's as far as I've
gotten with I just thought of this on
the way over here okay so I'd said I'd
I'd sit down and start working this out
and trying to figure out okay where's my
force equation going to come from and
I'm not exactly sure quiet but that
generally I'd go about setting it up
like that and start working those things
out okay any other question or questions
about the quiz
we're done early